[Music]
I've been working with marine mammals
from 40 years connect figure off when I
started working with seals and sea lions
it jabbed it out
I was under the impression that the
trainer was supposed to be in charge of
the session not the animal
okay that's how most aquariums do it but
I don't think that way is for good
[Music]
welcome to the New England Aquarium here
we have a selection of a million or so
annual visitors and here we have rattled
the turtle boy but we're really here to
introduce you to Kathy Streeter some
people call her the seal Whisperer and
this is for marine mammal team here at
the aquarium we have six harbor seals
sea lions and four northern fur seals
some of the animals were rescued and
some of them were born here good
like most aquarium trainers Kathy's team
trains their animals with food for
example we thought a harbor seal to
mimic the sound of our voice you can
utter how are you how are you well the
teams is something that most aquariums
dump they also interact with their
animals without food we call it play so
instead of us spending the day dictating
throughout what we want them to do we
are encouraging them to show us what
they would like us to do it's totally up
to them to track - right now we're
teaching her the strategy of just going
for the corner this where you going to
go on him here yes mirror mirror
string on a stick whena loves to play
with string type things it girl
ultimately I feel like it really
enriches the animals life to be able to
participate with us in a whole different
type of interaction and one that is just
not based on food the Wiis that is the
reinforcement instead of fish and in
ceará session we're to do Nina so stages
of learning how to play tic-tac-toe at
some point she started to vocalize so
she offered to do vocalizations
instead of doing the tic-tac-toe so we
learn through play you know what are
their preferences the standard comment
we get from trainers that visit some
other aquariums is that they're amazed
that we can spend time out on earth of
it with our seals and sea lions without
having food to interact with them you
know everybody would love to be able to
do that I think that play behavior for
children for adults and for animals is
all extremely valuable in the same
regard it just expands your brain
[Music]